chiropractor where do you hold your
stress
facts on facts on facts by the way
there's no way that those are the actual
shoulders I think there's some kind of
device there we Turtle like this as
humans and as a result a lot of people
have very tight cervical paraspinal
muscles as well as their traps if this
goes on for a very long period of time
we see that chronic changes in the spine
there well this person's taking a dirty
Fork to the patella looks like to the
quad tendon don't know why oh my God
wait what this isn't a human leg being
open because I've opened humans cadavers
and this is not what they look like
they're not chalky on the inside here's
this week's exercise to keep your brain
Nimble and build those super highways
well that's true the brain does actually
build super highways when you use it
Pinky finger switch them switch them
switch them switch them one more time
that's cool but like you can just do
activities that have a little bit more
meaning than this saw this kid doing a
workout incorrectly yeah I mean not
perfect form but not terrible either
I've seen that machine be misused so
many different ways
like that
the Halloween costume well okay this is
a family-friendly Channel wait she's
taking selfies like this why is there
other things inside the lips it could be
just a Halloween costume and we're
judging it if it's for any kind of
medical utility the answer is pretty
much no unless it's for like some kind
of endoscopy upper endoscopy then I'm
speaking outside of my own comfort zone
did you know that rubbing your
fingernails together like this dearly
stimulates the brain to send signals to
adult stem cells or it creates
paronychia
and fair Nikki are quite painful check
them out when I come home from work and
use my next stretcher I've seen this
thing Tick Tock and it looks so
ridiculous I can't imagine that it does
anything but I probably should try it
once before I knocked it just don't make
any claims
okay makes a guy mode when he comes home
I'm okay with that claim
going to bed drunk be like oh yeah the
spins baby it actually could be quite
dangerous if you are not awake enough to
puke that you can end up having some of
the vomit aspirated into your lungs and
cause infection and inflammation when
people say someone died of an overdose a
lot of times it's through this
aspirating their own vomit I'm gonna
show you how to reset your nervous
system in 30 seconds wow oh my God it's
like we're Windows PC put out your thumb
put out your other thumb and your
pointer finger and then you're going to
apply pressure for 20 seconds like this
and it really works it really doesn't
there's ways to actually stimulate one
of the main nerves in your body that is
responsible for parasympathetic tone and
that's your vagus nerve because it
innervates your diaphragm so if you're
able to go into deep breathing that can
actually change the way your body is
functioning with its parasympathetic
drive that works we're playing
everyone's favorite game this morning
you know it you love it let's say the
title together do I feel this way
because of the new prescription I just
started taking or because I ran out of
my other two prescriptions oh that's a
problematic game here's a little hint
the winner is not me especially if
you're on some mental health medications
that if you come off abruptly you can go
into withdrawal that can change how you
feel very quickly very uncomfortably the
German inventor Rebecca Weiss has
invented the testicle bath which uses
ultrasound technology to temporarily
stop sperm Mobility oh my God you know
it's funny in med school there was
always a joke that if you spend X number
of minutes in a hot tub with this
temperature you lose the ability to be
fertile for that short period of time
and everyone made a joke or go I'm going
to do that instead of using a condom and
no it's silly and not accurate and we
shouldn't do it very best part is it
only needs to be used once every couple
months in order to prevent pregnancy
yeah I don't know about that I need to
see the evidence before I start talking
about bathing testicles for birth
control all right guys let's talk about
Natalia Dyer from stranger things so if
I was Natalya's injector this is what I
would do are we really judging their
face and then saying what we're going to
do to their face I mean this is messed
up like you're basically saying
everything wrong with this person's face
like talk about giving someone a complex
I have a feeling after seeing this video
this person is going to go on and do the
same thing about me and be like his face
is unsalvishable all right let's see
what the final product would give up oh
that she faced how do we like my
Photoshop skills they suck when you go
see a plastic surgeon there should be a
conversation about body dysmorphia
before you undergo certain things but it
seems like this provider is just pushing
treatment on people who don't even want
it somebody lose their dog oh my God
that does look like my job bear come
here you have a friend here I heard
you're supposed to make them aware of
your surroundings like if this was a
black bear I would say hi black bear
come up I'm aware of my surroundings
please don't lick my face are you a
black bear or brown bear
your breath smells like fish oh my God
is it a chest compression skin oh my God
I need to see it is it good yo those are
good chest compressions yo those are two
inches deep good Rhythm that's better
than a human can probably do but I will
say where that machine probably won't
work is 99 of all chest compression
times when you need to chest compress
because chest compressions happen at
home on the street where you find people
down and that's where hands-only CPR
really needs to happen and guess what
most people aren't carrying that in
their back pocket a baby getting a Q-tip
I don't know if you're going in the ear
okay just witness here that's the
freakiest thing ever okay that doesn't
happen just saying this is not a natural
reflex there are all sorts of reflexes
that babies do which are actually kind
of adorable if you've ever seen like the
startle reflex if you were to fake drop
a baby the baby that naturally reaches
out to try and save themselves we check
these things Rob mcelhaney can you
please tell me how in the hell you got
so ripped putting us all into shame
after that transformation what you're
gonna need to do is you have a chef
right like like a personal chef so make
sure the Chef makes you a lot of chicken
breast and make sure you keep your
caloric intake at a certain level and as
you go to your physician two to three
times a week just to monitor all your
testosterone levels you don't need to
see your doctor multiple times a week to
check anything unless you actively have
a serious problem I can't remember the
last time I needed to see a patient
multiple times in a week you also don't
need to swear off food but yeah I get
what he's saying like to get an extreme
look in your body will take extreme
steps and that's not always healthy we
look at people who have ripped six-packs
and we assume that they're extremely
healthy that's not always the case
sometimes that comes at the cost of
their mental health which makes it
tremendously unhealthy oh
hey a little adductor work never hurt
nobody adductors are commonly strained
with exercise so you do need to
strengthen them and stretch them I don't
know why it needs to be in this room and
in this position in this outfit but to
each their own so when I first lost my
leg it was absolutely mind-blowing to me
how hungry I was every second of every
day especially when I started using my
prosthetic learning how to walk again
well you definitely will be using more
energy to adapt in the short term also
if you just got out of a surgery you're
also going to need more calories to heal
because that's a metabolic Demand on
your body especially as an amputee the
gift of being pretty mobile and pretty
active I am hungry all of the time if a
patient is overly hungry all of the time
like a year or two post surgery that is
a potential reason to do a further work
up you know talking about thyroid levels
cholesterol levels sugar levels Etc
because there are conditions that can
present themselves with feeling hungry
all the time this is day 292 of walking
on all fours every day our bodies
weren't made for this so you're going to
have extreme extreme Agony in your low
back length of your arms length of your
legs the muscle position the muscles
insertions the spinal cord it's not
meant for this type of walking we're
meant to walk upright so while this
could be a cool exercise I wouldn't
recommend this next time you eat pay
attention if your nose starts to run
your nose can start to run if you're
having an allergic reaction if you're
experiencing a viral illness if you get
increased circulation to your nasal
mucosa if you're eating and your nose
starts to run
stop eating if I eat something that's
not good for me my nose runs if I right
now have a little bit of spicy sauce my
nose is gonna run spicy sauce is not
necessarily bad for you and if I had a
tiny bit of it that also doesn't mean
I'm full so your thing just got debunked
on face value sorry to say what color
were my eyes oh wow I've heard of this
depositing ink medical intervention even
if it's for cosmetic purposes should be
eliminated at all costs so many things
can go wrong and then good luck figuring
out if you have a medical condition
after that and again like I want you to
express yourself but I want you to
express yourself without putting
yourself at risk
okay this is the weirdest thing I've
ever seen if anyone sends me this to the
P.O box that I have listed in my
description down below I will be very
shocked you're looking at the face of
someone who hasn't eaten cooked food in
almost five years cooked food is a
compromise it makes us sick and we don't
know it no my guy I've seen patients in
hospital settings where they can't cook
their foods and they have horrible
illnesses they lose their lives children
lose their lives why contaminated water
and contaminated food because they can't
cook them so from all the privilege that
we have from having all these clean
Foods there's many places in the world
where clean food's not an option so
let's be reasonable here if we just eat
raw food only it'll reverse all of our
health issues make us reversed and we'll
live forever Just ah so you know how you
go to the gym yeah you do your workouts
you do your abs well sometimes it's
usually in the morning middle of the day
whatever well I usually do it at night
you're doing it wrong why guys do your
abs before bed I do do that but why for
eight hours when you sleep you don't
drink you don't eat meaning your stomach
does not expand so those muscles you
just worked on work 10 times better than
when you usually just eat right after a
workout okay the logic is that because
your stomach is not expanding your
abdominal muscles which is separate from
your stomach muscles stay flat how does
that mean that they work harder once you
stop doing the abdominal workout the
repair begins it doesn't matter what's
going on in your stomach and doing abs
has nothing to do with fat just putting
that out there as well a working
supplement industry and I see a lot of
companies actually make up terms to
sound legit so you can pay more but
those terms actually have no meanings
yeah that's literally everything
in the supplement industry does not need
to be proven unless they make a claim
and then they actually hurt somebody
then the FDA starts to step in and act
on actually I don't think 15 the FDA I
think the FTC starts acting on it first
if they say they're tested by FDA
approved laboratory don't believe them
because FDA does not approve any
Laboratories what no what they say is an
FDA approved facility where other things
are made like when we did our bad doctor
thing we said it's an FDA approved
building and there's a rental space next
door second
party just
or they're tested third party is their
bro contains clinically tested
ingredients all ingredients in life
pretty much have been clinically tested
that means nothing those are just words
last if they say they're pharmaceutical
grade that's the best when they start
calling their supplements nutraceuticals
because they're like it's like almost
pharmaceutical our supplements if you
sell supplements only to doctors you're
doing it strictly to give yourself that
label not because there's any
restriction for you to sell them General
to the public when you forget to change
yourself oh no okay so do you know that
your feet prune as a way to give you
better stability inside a moist
environment it's not just like a
physical response it's an actual
neurological response oh my God bro
there's also probably a fungal component
there if you don't change your socks in
the field because that's going to trap
moisture Darkness all that stuff that
creates a good housing environment for
the fun guy in your life this is to
anyone thinking of getting freckles
centered on their face wow George it's
interesting people without freckles get
freckles tattooed on them people with
freckles pay for miracle serums to
remove the freckles the grass isn't
Greener I'm telling you this so they
call this the one minute health check
all you gotta do is take a spoon and
don't tell me and then place it under
some weight for about a minute and
you're technically healthy if you pick
back up the spoon and it's clean no
blotches or odor but if it does smell
kind of sharp there could be an issue
with your stomach hold up wait a minute
people look to you and they trust your
content and then you make stuff like
this which is just so obviously wrong I
can't watch this no no no hail doctor
spoon maybe that was comedy and I'm
judging it harshly for no reason so I
reserve because I don't know what
happens on Tick Tock but clearly
misinformation there and I hope it gets
demonetized taken down whatever they do
on Tick Tock look as you can see with so
many tick tocks you've got to be really
careful online it's so important you
don't just blindly trust random medical
advice videos you need to be able to
think for yourself and verify when
information is coming from a reliable
source that's why I'm actually so
excited to talk to you about the sponsor
of today's video brilliant a learning
tool that will help you expand not just
your knowledge but your ability to
understand the world around you as a
whole brilliant has thousands of lessons
with exclusive new content added monthly
on fascinating subjects like
astrophysics programming with python and
my favorite logic problems many of which
are actually designed to help you
identify Liars which should certainly
come in handy when trying to identify
misinformation online look when my
patients come to me to develop a healthy
lifestyle I always make sure that they
know long term consistent and manageable
Behavior changes are what's going to
give them long-term results that they're
looking for the same goes for your brain
and by just spending a few minutes a day
on brilliant studying something new it's
going to really benefit your mind for
the rest of your life to get started for
free brilliant.org Dr Mike remember
doctor is spelled out and click the link
in the description the first 200 of you
will get twenty percent off of
brilliant's annual premium subscription
My Life videos
and very fun check it out and as always
stay happy and healthy
[Music]